the jurogan experience
but the diagnosis of addiction is really
based on behaviors and can be briefly
summarized as the forces control
compulsion
craving
and consequences especially continued
use despite consequences so like what if
you're a like i have friends that are
addicted to golf
and they just can't wait to go play golf
what's the consequences
well it might be that their spouse says
gee whiz why are you playing golf all
the time maybe they just need a new
spouse well okay okay so
this actually comes up a lot in clinical
care like to what extent is it my
problem and to what extent do i have to
change my life right and and i always
say to patients you know that is a great
question and not one that i can answer
for you but maybe together we can find
the answer because the truth is
sometimes it is a question of needing to
change your life right and i wouldn't
presume to necessarily know especially
with cases on the border now there are
certainly on the border i mean on the
border of like um consequence
pathological yeah i mean there are some
cases where like okay you don't need to
be a psychiatrist to diagnose that this
person has addiction it seems open to
interpretation in the world of what you
would call extreme winners like the
michael jordans of the world the people
that are just absolutely completely
obsessed with winning
that seems like you could kind of call
that an addiction
but then they are the most celebrated
people in all of the world right so
you're you're tapping into something
that is really important to talk about
which is that
our society rewards certain types of
addictions and not others
we we certainly reward uh professional
athletes who have become obsessively
focused
on their sport
we certainly reward workaholics of all
types and again it's not to say that we
we should pathologize
all types of intensity
or all types of commitment to a behavior
that's not what it's about but what i
think is important is to recognize that
the same mental machinery that approach
and avoid behavior mediated by dopamine
that is at play when we become addicted
to something
can be at play really in all different
aspects of our lives not just drugs and
alcohol so you're essentially looking at
this very objectively you're not making
a judgment call you're just saying the
same mechanism is in place whether it is
extremely beneficial like you are
michael jordan or whether they're
extremely detrimental like you're a
person who's addicted to crack or you're
a gambling addict who keeps blowing all
their family's money it's kind of
you're on the same
human neurological pathway
that's exactly right it's this it's the
same
mental machinery that's you know being
applied
and
again there are certain types of
addictive behaviors that our society
rewards but even in those cases i think
it's important for people
to really closely evaluate potential
hidden consequences and i feel like
that's happening i mean just using the
example again of athletes i feel like
there are more more and more there are
athletes who are in different ways kind
of questioning
their lifestyle or the things that they
have to do
um
you know which i think is good i think
it's always good to look at the pros and
cons basically there's no there's never
the light without the dark you know it's
it's really that dialectic that comes
into play really in all aspects of our
lives which i think we need to talk
about and and think about
we ex we celebrate the people that are
extreme winners we we celebrate the
people that are absolutely completely
obsessed with performance
and they have everything dialed in
including their calories their
macronutrients the amount of sleep they
have the amount of recovery that they
seek out how they do it
um
but
but they have a massive reward for that
right the massive reward is the glory of
being a michael jordan or being a mike
tyson or being a
sugar ray leonard or whoever it is at
the the peak of their performance when
they're on top of the world
there's a great
deal of benefit to having
what many would just call extreme
discipline
yes so what's wrong with that
well
what we hear very little about is when
that road comes to an end and that
escalating glory and reward dries up and
what those people's lives are like after
that
and my sense is that unless they've
worked very hard to cultivate other
aspects of their personality when that
dopamine trail dries up because they get
injured or they just age yeah
then they have to contend with you know
the come down
um you know the dopamine deficit state
not to mention all of the other aspects
related to um loss of identity you know
who am i if i'm not this person who's
winning and of course that's an old
trope i mean we know that but we don't
we don't hear about those those athletes
after that the other thing i would say
that
that you know
that you point out in that description
which i think is also key to the process
of becoming addicted is the ways in
which
addiction is also about
controlling and changing the way we feel
in the moment rather than tolerating
the feelings or the uncertainty of
what's next and letting it wash over us
so a really key important
aspect of what you call discipline but
which i think in some context might be
addiction
is
wanting to control what we're feeling
you know when we feel it and i think
this is also deeply embedded into modern
life and modern culture explain that
with wanting to control what we're
feeling and when we feel it yes and
that's what separates discipline from
addiction no i think i think those are
there's overlap there so let me let me
go back so
part of
part of what drives the phenomenon of
addiction
is that
people control what they feel when they
feel it so for example you know um
in this moment let's say i'm struggling
right but i feel like oh i can get
through this because when this is over
i'm not saying i'm struggling but i mean
if i work
yeah but because when this is over i'm
going to reward myself with x y so like
if you go running and then afterwards
you can have a slice of pizza that's
right exactly so it's the way that we
bracket our endeavors with rewards and
this is just like deeply embedded into
our culture and the control aspect is is
is a big part of the addictive aspect
because i'm now going to control the way
i feel when i feel it which is a very
different way of living if you were to
eliminate
rewards as a way to shape time if you
were to think
i'm not going to do anything to reward
myself today i'm just going to
get through the day it totally changes
the arc of of our experience in the
moment
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify